the curious narrative that follows was
found among the papers of the late dr.
john pendrick psychical investigator and
author of occult works it bears evidence
of having been received through
automatic writing as were several of his
publications unfortunately there are no
records to confirm this assumption and
none of the mediums or assistants
employed by him in his research work
admits knowledge of it possibly for the
doctor was reputed to possess some
psychic powers it may have been received
by him at any rate the lack of data
renders the recital useless as a
document for the Society for psychical
research it is published for whatever
intrinsic interest or significance it
may possess with reference to the names
mentioned it may be added that they are
not confirmed by the records of the War
Department
it could be maintained however that
purposely fictitious names were
substituted either by the doctor or by
the communicating entity they called me
when I walked the earth and a body of
dense matter Richard Devaney though my
story has little to do with war I was
killed in the Second Battle of the Marne
on July 24th 1918 many times as men were
want to do who felt the daily hourly
imminence of death in the trenches I had
pictured that event in my mind and
wondered what it would be like mainly I
had inclined toward a belief in total
extinction that when the vigorous
full-blooded body I possessed should
live bereft of its faculties I is a
creature apart from it should go on was
beyond credence the play of life through
the human machine I reasoned was like
the flow of gasoline into the motor of
an automobile shut off that flow and the
motor became inert dead while the fluid
which had given it power was in itself
nothing and so I confess it was a
surprise to discover that I was dead and
yet not dead
I did not make the discovery at once
there had been a blinding concussion a
moment of darkness a sensation of
falling falling into a deep abyss an
indefinite time afterward I found myself
standing dazed idli on the hillside
toward the crest of which we had been
pressing against the enemy the thought
came that I must have momentarily left
consciousness yet now I felt strangely
free from physical discomfort what had I
been doing when that moment of blackness
blotted everything out I had been
dominated by a purpose a flaming desire
like a flash recollection burst upon me
and with it a blaze of hatred not toward
the bush Gunners ensconced in the woods
above but toward the private enemy I had
been about to kill it had been the
opportunity for which I had waited
interminable days and nights in the open
formation he kept a few paces ahead of
me
as we alternately ran forward then
dropped on our bellies and fired I had
watched my chance no one would suspect
with the dozens who were falling every
moment under the merciless fire from the
trees beyond that the bullet which ended
Lois Winston's career came from a
comrades rifle twice I had taken aim but
withheld my fire
not from indecision but lest in my
vengeful heat I might fail to reach a
vital spot when I raised my rifle the
third time he offered a fair target god
how I hated him with fingers itching to
speed the steel toward his heart I
forced myself to remain calm to hold
fire for that fragment of a second that
would ensure careful aim
then as the pressure of my finger
tightened against the trigger came the
blinding flash the moment of blackness I
had evidently remained unconscious
longer than I realized
save for a few figures that lay
motionless are squirming in agony on the
field the regiment had passed on to be
lost in the trees at the crest of the
hill with a pang of disappointment I
realized that Lois would be among them
involuntarily I started onward driven
still by that impulse of burning hatred
when I heard my name called turning in
surprise I saw a helmeted figure
crouching beside something huddled in
the tall grass no second glance was
needed to tell me that the huddled
something was the body of a soldier I
had eyes only for the man who was
bending over him faith had been kind to
me it was Lois apparently in his
preoccupation he had not noticed me
coolly I raised my rifle and fired the
result was startling Lois neither
dropped headlong nor looked up at the
report vaguely I questioned whether
there had been a report for did I felt
the lust to kill mounting in me with
redoubled fury with rifle upraised I ran
toward him a terrific swing and I
crashed the stock against his head it
passed clear through Lois remained
unmoved uncomprehending snarling I flung
the useless weapon away and fell upon
him with bare hands with fingers that
strained to rend and tear and strangle
instead of encountering solid flesh and
bone they too passed through him was it
a mirage a dream had I gone crazy
sobered for a moment forgetful of my
fury I drew back and tried to reduce the
thing to reason was Lois but a figment
of the imagination a phantom
my glance fell upon the figure beside
which he was sobbing and coherent words
of entreaty I gave a start then looked
more closely the dead man for there was
no question about his condition with a
bloody shrapnel wound in the side of his
head was myself gradually the import of
this penetrated my consciousness then I
realized that it was Lewis who had
called my name but even now he was
sobbing it over and over the irony of it
struck me at the moment of realization I
was dead I was the Phantom who had meant
to kill Lewis I looked at my hands my
uniform I touched my body apparently I
was as substantial as before the
shrapnel buried itself in my head yet
when I had tried to grasp Lewis my hands
seemed to encompass only space Lewis
lived and I was dead the discovery for a
time benumbed my feeling toward him with
impersonal curiosity I saw him closed
the eyes of the dead man the man who
somehow or other had been me I saw him
search the pockets and draw forth a
letter I had written only that morning a
letter addressed to with a sudden surge
of dismay I darted forward to snatch it
from his hands he should not read that
letter again I was reminded of my
impalpable 'ti but Lewis did not open
the envelope although it was unsealed he
read the superscription kissed it as
sobs rent his frame and thrust the
letter inside his khaki jacket dick
buddy he cried brokenly
best pal a man ever had how can I take
this news back to her my lips curled to
Lewis I was his pal his buddy not a
suspicion of the hate I bore him had
borne him ever since I discovered in him
arrival for Velma Roth ho I had been
clever
it was our unselfish friendship that
endeared us both to her a sign of
jealousy of ill nature and I would have
forfeited the paradise of her regard
that apparently has shared with Lewis
I had never felt secure of my place in
that paradise true I could always awaken
a response center but I must put forth
effort in order to do so he held her
interest it seemed without trying they
were happy with each other and in each
other our relations might be expressed
by likening her to the water of a placid
pool Louis to the basin that held her me
to the wind that swept over it by
exerting myself I could a j't ate the
surface of her nature into ripples of
pleasurable excitement could even lash
her emotions into a tempest she
responded to the stimulation of my mood
yet in my absence
settled contentedly into the peaceful
comfort of Louis's steadfast love I felt
vaguely then and uncertain now with a
broader perspective toward realities
that Velma intuitively recognized Lewis
as her mate yet feared to yield herself
to him because of my sway over her
emotional nature when the Great War came
we all I'm convinced felt that it would
absolve Velma from the task of choosing
between us whether the agony that spoke
from the violet depths of her eyes when
we said goodbye was chiefly for Lewis or
for me I could not tell I doubt if she
could have done so but in my mind was
the determination that only one of us
should return and Lewis would not be
that one did I feel repugnance at the
thought of murdering the man who stood
in my way very little I was a savage at
heart a savage in whom desire outweighed
anything that might stand in the way of
gaining its object from my point of view
I would have been a fool to pass up the
opportunity why I should have so hated
him a mere obstacle in my path I do not
know it may have been due to a
precedence of the intangible barrier his
blood would always raise between Velma
and me or to a slumbering sense of
remorse but speculation aside here I was
in a state of being that the world calls
death while Lewis lived was free to
return home to claim Velma to flaunt his
possession of all that I held precious
it was maddening must I stand idly by
helpless to prevent this
I have wondered since how I could remain
so long in touch with the objective
world why I did not at once are very
soon find myself shut off from earthly
sights and sounds as those in physical
form are shut off from the things beyond
the matter seems to have been determined
by my will like weights of lead envy of
Lois and passionate longing for Velma
held my feet to the sphere of dense
matter vengeful despairing I watched
beside Lois when at last he turned away
from my body and with tears streaming
from his eyes began to drag a useless
leg toward the trenches we had left I
realized why he had not gone on with the
others to the crest of the hill he too
was a victim of bush gunnery I walked
beside the stretcher-bearer
when they had picked him up and were
conveying him toward the base hospital
throughout the weeks that followed i
hovered near his cot watching the
doctors as they bound up the lacerated
tendons in his thigh and detailed his
battle with the fever
over his shoulder I read the first
letter he wrote home to Velma in which
he gave a belated account of my death
dwelling upon the glory of my sacrifice
I have often thought that you two were
meant for each other
he wrote and that if it had not been for
fear of hurting me
you would have been his wife long ago he
was the best buddy a man ever had if
only I could have been the one to die
had I known it I could have followed
this letter across seas could in fact
have passed it and by an exercise of the
will have been at Velma's side in the
twinkling of an eye but my ignorance of
the laws of the new plane was total all
my thoughts were centered upon a problem
of entirely different character never
was hold upon earthly treasure more
reluctantly relinquished than was my
hope of possessing Velma surely death
could not erect so absolute a barrier
there must be away some loophole of
communication some chance for a
disembodied man to contend with his
corporal rival for a woman's love slowly
very slowly dawned a light of a plan so
feeble was the glimmer that it would
scarcely have comforted one in less
desperate straits but
me it appeared to offer a possible hope
I said about methodically with infinite
patience evolving it into something
tangible even though I had but the most
indefinite idea of what the outcome
might be the first suggestion came when
Lewis had so far recovered that but
little trace of the fever remained when
afternoon as he lay sleeping the male
distributor handed a letter to the nurse
who happened to be standing beside his
cot she glanced at it then tucked it
under his pillow the letter was from
Velma and I was hungry for the contents
I did not then know that I could have
read it easily sealed though it was in a
frenzy of impatience I exclaimed
wake up confound it and read your letter
with a start he opened his eyes he
looked around with a bewildered
expression under your pillow i fumed
look under your pillow in a dazed manner
he put his hand out of the pillow and
drew forth a letter a few hours later I
heard him commenting on the experience
to the nurse something seemed to wake me
up he said and I had a peculiar impulse
to feel under the pillow it was just as
if I knew I would find the letter there
the circumstances seemed as remarkable
to me as it did to him it might be a
coincidence but I determined to make a
further test a series of experiments
convinced me that I could to a very
slight degree impressed my thoughts and
will upon Lewis especially when he was
tired or on the borderland of sleep
occasionally I was able to control the
direction of his thoughts as he wrote
home to Velma
on one occasion he was describing for
her a funny little French woman who
visited the hospital with a basket that
was always filled with cigarettes and
candy last time he wrote she brought
with her a boy whom she called he paused
with pencil upraised trying to recall
the name
a moment later he looked down at the
page and stared with astonishment the
words she called him Maurice had been
added below the unfinished line I must
be going Daffy he muttered I swear I
didn't write that behind him
I stood rubbing my hands in triumph it
was my first successful effort to guide
the pencil while his thoughts strayed
elsewhere another time he wrote to Velma
I have a strange feeling lately that
dear old dick is near sometimes as I
wake up I seem to remember vaguely
having seen him in my dreams it's as if
his features were just fading from view
he paused here so long that I made
another attempt to take advantage of his
abstraction by an effort of the will
that it is difficult to explain I guided
his hand into the formation of the words
with a junk full of kisses for Winky as
ever her just then Louis looked down
good god he exclaimed as if he had seen
a ghost Winky was a pet name I had given
Velma when we were children together
Louis always maintained there was no
sense in it and refused to adopt it
though I frequently called her by the
name in later years and of his own
volition Louis would never have
mentioned anything convivial as a jug
full of kisses so through the weary
months before he was invalid at home I
worked when he left France at the
demarcation point he still walked on
crutches but with the promise of
regaining the unassisted use of his leg
before very long throughout the voyage I
hovered near him sharing his impatience
his longing for the one we both held
theorist over the exquisite pain of the
reunion at which I was present yet not
present I shall pass briefly more
beautiful than ever more appealing with
her vivid deep coloring Velma in the
flesh was a vision that stirred my
longing into an intense flame Lewis
limped painfully down the gangplanks
when they met she rested her head
silently on his shoulder for a moment
then her eyes brimming with tears
assisted him with the tender solicitude
of a mother to the machine she had in
waiting two months later they were
married I felt the pain of this less
deeply than I would have done
had it not been essential to my design
whatever vague hope I might have had
however of vicariously enjoying the
delights of love were disappointed I
could not have explained why I only knew
that something barred me from intruding
upon the sacred intimacy's of their life
as if a defensive wall were interposed
it was baffling but a very present fact
against which I found it useless to
rebel I have since learned but no matter
this had no bearing on my purpose which
hinged on the ability I was acquiring of
influencing Lewis's thoughts and actions
of taking partial control of his
faculties the occupation into which he
drifted restricted in choice as he was
by the stiffened leg helped me
materially often after an interminable
shift at the bank he would plod home at
night with brains so weak and been
numbed that it was a simple matter to
impress my will upon him each successful
attempt to made the next one easier the
inevitable consequence was that in time
Velma should notice his aberrations and
betray concern why did you say to me
when you came in last night there's a
blue billy goat on the stairs I wish
they drive him out she demanded one
morning he looked down shamefacedly at
the tablecloth I don't know what made me
say it
I seem to want to say it and that was
the only way to get it off my mind I
thought you'd take it as a joke he
shifted his shoulders as if trying to
dislodge an unpleasant burden and was
that what made you wear a necktie to bed
she asked ironically he nodded an
affirmative I knew it was idiotic
but the idea kept running in my mind it
seemed as if the only way I could go to
sleep was to give in to it I don't have
these freaks unless I'm very tired she
said nothing more at the time but that
evening she broached the subject of his
looking for an opening in some less
sedentary occupation a subject to which
she thereafter constantly recurred then
came a development that surprised and
excited me with its possibilities
exhausted drained to the last drop of
his nerve force Lewis was returning late
one night from the bank following the
usual month end overtime grind as he
walked from the car line I hovered over
him subdue his personality forcing it
under control with the effort of will I
had gradually learned to direct upon him
the process can only be explained in a
crude way It was as if I contended with
him sometimes successfully for
possession of the steering wheel of the
human car that he drove Thelma was
waiting when we arrived Louis's feet
sounded on the threshold of their
apartment she opened the door caught his
hands and drew him inside at the action
I felt inexplicably thrilled It was as
if some marvelous change had come over
me and then as I met her gaze I knew
what that change was I held her hands in
real flesh-and-blood contact I was
looking at her with Lewis's sight the
shock of it cost me what I had gained
shaken from my poise I felt the
personality I had subdued regain its
sway the next moment
Lewis was staring at Velma and
bewilderment her eyes were filled with
alarm you frightened me she gasped
withdrawing her hands which I had all
but crushed Lewis dear don't ever look
at me again like that I can imagine the
devouring intensity of gaze that had
blazed forth from the features in that
brief moment when they were mine from
this time my plans quickly took form two
modes of action presented themselves the
first and more alluring however I was
forced to abandon it was none other than
the wild dream of Lewis's body of
forcing him down out and into the
secondary place I had occupied despite
the progress I had made this proved
inexpressibly difficult for one thing
there seemed an affinity between Lewis's
body and his personality which forced me
out when he was moderately rested this
bond I might have weakened but there
were other factors one was the growing
conviction on his part that something
was radically wrong
with a faculty I had discovered of
putting myself and rapport with him and
reading his thoughts I knew that at
times he feared that he was going insane
I once had the experience of
accompanying him to an Alienist and
they're like the proverbial fly on the
wall overhearing learning scientific
names applied to my efforts the Alienist
spoke of dual personality amnesia and
the subconscious mind while I laughed
and my shall I say ghostly sleeve but he
advised Louis to seek a complete rest
and if possible to go into the country
to build up physically which was what I
desired most to prevent I could not play
the mr. Hyde to his dr. Jekyll if Lewis
maintained his normal virility Velma's
fears - I knew were growing more acute
as insistently as she could without
betraying to openly her alarm she
pressed him to give up the bank position
and to seek work in the open air work
that would prove less Dee vitalizing to
a person of his peculiar temperament one
of the results of debility from overwork
is apparently that it deprives the
victim of his initiative makes him
fearful of giving up his hold upon the
meager means of sustenance that he has
lest he shall be unable to grasp another
Lewis was in debt earning scarcely
enough for their living expenses too
proud to let Velma help as she longed to
do his game leg putting him at a
disadvantage in the industrial field in
fact he was in just the predicament I
desired but I knew that in time her
wishes would prevail the circumstances
however that deprived me of all hope of
completely usurping his place was this I
could not for any length of time face
the gaze of Velma's eyes the personified
truth the purity that dwelt in them
seemed to dissolve my power to beat me
back into the secondary relationship I
had come to occupy toward Lewis
he was sometimes tempted to tell her you
give me my one grip on sanity I've
witnessed his panic at the thought of
losing her at the thought that someday
she might give him up and disgust at his
operations and abandoned him to the
formless thing that haunted him curious
to be of the world and yet not of it to
enjoy a perspective that reveals the
hidden side of effects which seems so
mysterious from the material side of the
veil but I would gladly have given all
the advantages of my disembodied State
for one hour of flesh and blood
companionship with Velma my alternative
plan was this if I could not enter her
world what was to prevent me from
bringing Velma into mine daring to be
sure Unversed as I was and the laws that
govern this mystery of passing from the
physical into another state of existence
I can only hope that the plan would work
it might and that was enough for me I
took a gambler's chance by risking all I
might gain all might gain the thought of
what I might gain transported me to a
heaven of pain and ecstasy Velma and I
in a world apart a world of our own free
from the sordid trammels that Mar the
perfection of the rosiest earth
existence Velma and I together through
all eternity this much reason I had for
hoping I observed that other persons
passed through the change called death
and that some entered a state of being
in which I was conscious of them and
they of me uninteresting creatures they
were almost wholly preoccupied with
their former Earth interests but they
were as much in the world as I had been
in the world of Velma and Lewis before
that fragment of shrapnel ruled me out
of the game a few it was true on passing
from their physical habitations seemed
to emerge into a sphere to which I could
not follow this troubled me Velma might
do likewise yet I refused to admit the
probability refused to consider the
possible failure of my plan the very
intensity of my longing would draw her
to me the gulf that separated us was
spanned by the grave once Velma had
crossed to my side of the abyss there
would be no going back to Lewis
yet I was cunning she must not come to
me with overpowering regrets that would
cause her to hover about Louis as I now
hovered about her if I can inspire her
with horror and loathing for him if I
only could as a preliminary step
I must induce Louis to buy the
instrument with which my purpose was to
be accomplished this was not easy for on
nights when he left the bank during
shopping hours he was sufficiently
vigorous to resist my will I could work
only through suggestion in a pawn shop
window that he passed daily I had
noticed a revolver prominently displayed
my whole effort was concentrated upon
bringing this to his attention the
second night he glanced at the revolver
but did not stop three nights later
drawn by a fascination for which he
could not have accounted he paused and
looked at it for several minutes
fighting an urge that seemed to command
step in and bye-bye
when a few evenings later he arrived
home with a revolver and a box of
cartridges that the pawnbroker had
included in the sale he put them hastily
out of sight in a drawer of his desk he
said nothing about his purchase but the
next day Velma came across the weapon
and questioned him regarding it visibly
confused he replied oh I thought we
might need something of the sort saw it
in a window and the notion of having it
just sort of took hold of me there's
been a lot of housebreaking lately and
it's just as well to be prepared and now
with impatience
I waited for the opportunity to stage my
daenam all it came naturally at the end
of the month when Louis after a
prolonged day's work returned home soon
after midnight his brain been numbed
with poring over interminable columns of
figures when his feet ascended the
stairs to his apartment it was not his
faculties that directed them but mine
running alert a flame with deadly
purpose
never was there more weird preliminary
to a murder the entering in guise of a
dear familiar form of a fiend incarnate
intent upon destroying the flower of the
home I speak of a fiend incarnate even
though I was that fiend for I did not
enter Lewes his body and full expression
of my faculties taking up physical life
my recollection of existence as a spirit
entity was always shadowy I carried
through the dominating impulses that had
actuated me on entering the body but
scarcely more and the impulse I had
carried through that night was the
impulse to kill with that most caution I
entered the bedroom my control of
Lewis's body was complete I felt for
perhaps the first time so corporeally
secure that the vague dread of being
driven out did not oppress me the room
was dark but the soft regular breathing
of Velma asleep reached my ears it was
like the invitation that rises in the
scent of old wine which the lips are
about to quaff quickening my eagerness
and setting my brain on fire I did not
think of love I lusted but my lust to
destroy that beautiful body to kill
however I was cunning with caution
I felt my way toward the desk and
secured the revolver filling its
chambers with leaden emissaries of death
when all was in readiness I switched on
the light she wakened almost instantly
as the radiance flooded the room a
startled cry rose to her lips
it froze unuttered as half rising she
met my gaze her beauty the even
blackness of her hair falling over her
bare shoulders and full heaving bosom
fanned the flame of my gory passion into
fury in an ecstasy of triumph I stood
drinking in the picture while I
temporized with the lust to kill
prolonging the exquisite sensation he
was battling for self control Lewis the
name was gasped through bloodless lips
involuntarily I shrunk reeling a little
under her gaze a dormant something
seemed to rise in feeble protest at what
I sought to do
leveled revolver wavered in my hand but
the note of panic in her voice revived
my purpose I laughed mockingly Lewis her
tone was sharp but edged with terror
Lewis put down that pistol you don't
know what you're doing she struggled to
her feet and now stood before me God how
beautiful how tempting that bear white
bosom put down that pistol she ordered
hysterically she was frantic with fear
and her fear was like the blast of a
forge upon the white heat of my passion
i mocked her a shrill maniacal laugh
burst for my throat she had said I
didn't know what I was doing oh yes I
did I'm going to kill you I shrieked and
laughed again she swayed forward like a
wraith as I fired or perhaps that was
the trick played by my eyes as darkness
overwhelmed me a few fragmentary
pictures stand out in my recollection
like clear edged cameos on the scroll of
the past
one is of Lewis standing dazed idli
slightly swaying as with vertigo looking
down at the smoking revolver in his hand
on the floor before him a crumpled
figure in Ebony in white and vivid
crimson then a confusion of frightened
men and women in oddly assorted
nondescript attire uniformed officers
bursting into the room and taking the
revolver from Lewis's unresisting hand
clumsy efforts at lifting the white
robed body to the bed a crimson stain
spreading over the sheet a doctor
attired and collarless shirt and wearing
slippers bending over her finally after
a lapse of hours a hushed atmosphere
efficient nurses the beginning of
delirium and one other picture of Lewis
cringing behind the bars of his cell
denied the privilege of visiting his
wife's bedside crushed dreading the
hourly announcement of her death filled
with unspeakable horror of himself
Velma still lived the bullet had pierced
her left lung and life hung by a tenuous
thread hovering near I watched with
dispassionate interest the battle for
life for the time I seemed emotionally
spent I had made a supreme effort events
would now take their inevitable course
and show whether I had accomplished my
purpose I felt neither anxious nor
overjoyed
neither regretful more triumphant merely
in personally curious a fever set in
lessening Velma's slender chances of
recovery in her delirium her thoughts
seemed always a Lois sometimes she
breathed his name pleadingly tenderly
then cried out in terror at some
fleeting rehearsal of the scene in which
he stood before her the glitter of
insanity in his eyes the levelled
revolver in his hand again she pleaded
with him to give up his work at the bank
and at other times she seemed to think
of him as over on the battlefields of
Europe only once did she apparently
think of me when she whispered the name
by which I had called her Winkie an
added dick but save for this exception
it was always Lewis Lewis her constant
reiteration of his name finally
dispelled the apathy of my spirit Lewis
all the vengeful fury toward him I had
experienced when my soul went hurtling
into the region of the disembodied
returned with warded intensity when
Velma's fever subsided when the long
fight for recovery began and she
fluttered from the borderlands back into
the realm of the physical when I knew I
had failed balked of my prey I had at
least this satisfaction never again with
these two the man I hated and the woman
for whom I hungered never again would
they be to each other as they had been
in the past the perfection of their love
had been irretrievably marred never
would she meet his gaze without an
inward shrinking always on his part on
both their parts
there would be an undercurrent of fear
that the incident might recur a grisly
menace poisoning each moment of their
lives together I had not schemed and
contrived and dared in vain
this was the thought I hugged when Lewis
was released from jail upon her refusal
to prosecute it caused me sardonic
amusement when in their first embrace
the tears of despair rained down their
cheeks it recurred when they began their
pitiful attempt to build anew on the
shattered foundation of love and then
creepingly slyly like a bird of ill omen
casting the shadow of its silent wings
over the landscape came retribution many
times in retrospect I lived over that
brief hour of my return to physical
expression my hour of realization ray
flake arose a vision of Velma Velma as
she had stood before me that night
staring at me with horror I saw the
horror deepen deep into abject despair
how beautiful she had looked but when I
tried to picture that beauty I could
recall only her eyes it mattered not
whether I wish to see them they filled
my vision they seemed to haunt me from
being vaguely conscious of them I became
acutely so disconcertingly they looked
out at me from everywhere eyes brimming
with fear eyes fixed in staring filled
with horrified accusation the beauty I
had once coveted became a thing
forbidden even in memory if I sought to
peer through the veil as formerly to
witness her pathetic attempts to resume
the old life with Lewis again those eyes
it may perhaps aound strange for a
disembodied creature one whom you would
call a ghost to wail of being haunted
yet haunting is of the spirit and we of
the spirit world are immeasurably more
subject to its conditions than those
whose consciousness is centered in the
material sphere god those eyes there is
a refinement of physical torture which
consists of allowing water to fall drop
by drop for an eternity of hours upon
the forehead of the victim conceive of
this torture increased a thousandfold
and a faint idea may be gained of the
torture that was mine from seeing
everywhere constantly interminably two
orbs ever filled with the same
expression of horror and reproach
much have I learned since entering the
land of the shades at that time I did
not know as I know now that my
punishment was no affliction from
without but the simple result of natural
law cause said in motion must work out
their full reaction the pebble cast into
a quiet pool makes ripples which in time
returned to the place of their origin i
had cast more than a pebble of
disturbance in the harmony of human life
and through my intense preoccupation in
a single aim had delayed longer than
usual the reaction I had created for
myself a hell inevitably I was drawn
into it gone was every desire I had
known to hover near the two who would so
long engrossed my attention haunted
harried by those dreadful accusers I
sought to fly from them to the ends of
the earth there was no escape yet driven
frantic I still struggled to escape
because that is the impulse of suffering
creatures the emotions that had so
swayed me when I tried to blast the
lives of two who held me dear now seemed
puny and insignificant in comparison
with my suffering no physical torment
can be likened to that which engulfed me
until my very being was but a seething
mass of agony through it I hurled
maledictions upon the world upon myself
upon the Creator horrible blasphemies I
uttered and at last I prayed it was but
a cry for mercy the inarticulate appeal
of a tortured soul for surcease of pain
but suddenly a great peace seemed to
have come upon the universe bereft of
suffering I felt like one who is ceased
to exist out of the silence came a
wordless response it beat upon my
consciousness like the buffeting of the
waves words known to human ears would
not convey the meaning of the message
that was borne upon me whether from
outside source are welling up from
within I do not know all I know is that
it filled me with a strange hope a
thousand years or a single instant for
time is a relative thing the respite
lasted then I sank as it seemed to the
old level of consciousness and the
torment was renewed
endure it now I knew that I must and why
a strange new purpose filled my being
the light of understanding had dawned
upon my soul and so I came to resume my
vigil in the home of Velma and Louis a
brave heart was Velma's dauntless and
true with the effects of the tragedy
still apparent in her pallor and
weakness and in the shaken demeanor and
furtive self-distrust phul attitude of
Louis she yet succeeded in finding a
place for him as overseer of a small
country estate I have said that I ceased
to feel the torment of passion for Velma
in the greater torment of her reproach
ah but I had never ceased to love her as
I now realized I had desecrated that
love had transmuted it into a horrible
travesty had in my abysmal ignorance
sought to obtain what I desired by
destroying it yet beneath all I had
loved well I know now that had I
succeeded in my intention toward her
Velma would have ascended to a sphere
utterly beyond my comprehension merciful
fate had diverted my aim had made
possible some faint restitution I
returned to Velma loving her with a love
that had come into its own a love
unselfish untainted by thought of
possession but to help her I must again
hurt her cruelly out of the chaos of her
life she had slowly restored a semblance
of harmony she almost succeeded in
convincing Lewis that their old peaceful
companionship had returned but to one
who could read her thoughts the
nightmare thing that hovered between
them Wade cruelly upon her soul she was
never quite able to look into her
husband's eyes without a lurking
suspicion of what might lie in their
depths never able to compose herself or
sleep without a tremor lest she should
wake to find herself confronted by a
fiend in his form I had done my work
only too well now slowly and inexorably
I began again undermining Louis's mental
control the old ground must be traversed
and new because he had gained in
strength from the respite I had allowed
him and his outdoor life gave him a
mental vigour with which I had not been
obliged to contend before on the other
hand I was equipped with new knowledge
of the power I intended to wield
I shall not relate again the successive
stages by which I succeeded first and
influencing his will then and partially
subduing it and finally and driving his
personality into the background for
indefinite periods the terror that
overwhelmed him when he realized that he
was becoming a prey to his former
aberrations may be imagined to shield
Velma I performed my experiments when
possible while he was away from her but
she could not long be unaware of the
moodiness the Haggard droop of his
shoulders which accompanied his
realization that the old malady had
returned the deepening terror and her
expression was like a scourge upon my
spirit but I must wound her in order to
cure more than once I was forced to
exert my power over Luis to prevent him
from taking violent measures against
himself as I gained the ascendancy a
determination to end it all grew upon
him he feared that unless he took
himself out of Velma's life the insanity
would return and force him again to
commit a frenzied assault upon the one
he held most dear nor could he avoid
seeing the apprehension in her manner
that told him that she knew the
shrinking that she bravely tried to
conceal though my power over him was
greater than before it was intermittent
I could not always exercise it I could
not for example prevent his borrowing a
revolver one day from a neighbouring
farmer on pretence of using it against a
marauding dog that had lately visited
the poultry yard though I knew his true
intention the utmost that I could do for
his personality was strong at the time
was to influence him to postpone the
deed he contemplated that night I took
possession of his body while he slept
Velma lay breathing quietly in the next
room for as this dreaded thing came upon
him they had through tacit understanding
come to occupy separate bedrooms
partially dressing I stole downstairs
and out to the toolshed where Lois
fearing to trust it near him in the home
had hidden the revolver as I returned my
whole being rebelled at the task before
me yet it was unavoidable if it would
restore to Velma what I had wrenched
from her
quietly though I entered her room a gasp
or rather a quick hysterical intake of
breath warned me that she had awakened I
flashed on the light she made no sound
her face went white as marble the
expression in her eyes was that which
had tortured me into the depths of a
hell more frightful than any conceived
by human imagination a moment I stood
swaying before her was levelled revolver
as I had stood on that other occasion
months before slowly I lowered the
revolver and smiled not as Louis would
have smiled but as a maniac formed in
his likeness would have smiled her lips
framed the word Louis but in the grip of
despair she made no sound
it was the despair not merely of a woman
who felt herself doomed to death but of
a woman who consigned her loved one to a
fate worse than death
still I smiled with growing difficulty
for Louis's personality was restive and
my time in the usurped body was short in
that moment I was not anxious to give up
his body at this new glimpse of her
beauty through physical sight my love
for Velma flamed in a hitherto
unrealized intensity for an instant my
purpose in returning was forgotten
forgotten was the knowledge at the ages
which I had sipped since last I acupiont
forgotten was everything save Velma as I
took a step forward my arms outstretched
my eyes expressing god-knows-what depths
of yearning she uttered a scream
blackness surged over me I stumbled I
was being forced out that cry of Terror
had vibrated through the soul of Louis
and he was struggling to answer it
instinctively I battled against the
darkness clung to my hard-won ascendancy
a moment of conflict and again I
prevailed
once more I smiled the effect of it must
have been weird for I was growing weaker
and Louis had returned to the attack
with overwhelming persistence my tongue
strove for expression sorry
Winkie it won't happen again I'm not
coming back
when I recovered from the momentary
unconsciousness that accompanies
transition from the physical to
spiritual Lewis was looking in a fright
at the huddled figure of Velma who had
fainted away the next instant he had
gathered her in his arms though I had
come near failing in the attempt to
deliver my message I had no fear that my
visit would prove in vain with clear
precedence I knew that my utterance of
that old familiar nickname Winkie would
carry untold meaning to Velma that
hereafter she would fear no more which
she might see in the depths of her
husband's eyes that with a return of her
old confidence in him the specter of
apprehension would be banished forever
from their lives
[Music]
mr. Bessel was the senior partner in the
firm of Bessel heart and brown of st.
Paul's churchyard and for many years he
was well known among those interested in
psychical research as a liberal minded
and conscientious investigator he was an
unmarried man and instead of living in
the suburbs after the fashion of his
class he occupied rooms in the Albany
near Piccadilly he was particularly
interested in the questions of thought
transference and of apparitions of the
living and in November 1896 he commenced
a series of experiments in conjunction
with mr. Vincey of staple in in order to
test the alleged possibility of
projecting an apparition of oneself by
force of will through space their
experiments were conducted in the
following manner at a pre-arranged hour
mr. Bessel shut himself in one of his
rooms in the Albany and mr. Vincey in
his sitting room its staple Inn and each
then fixed his mind as resolutely as
possible on the other mr. Bessel had
acquired the art of self hypnotism and
so far as he could he attempted first to
hypnotize himself and then to project
himself as a phantom of the living
across the intervening space of nearly
two miles into mr. vincey's apartment on
several evenings this was tried without
any satisfactory result but on the fifth
or sixth occasion mr. Vincey did
actually see or imagined he saw an
apparition of mr. Bessel standing in his
room he states that the appearance
although brief was very vivid and real
he noticed that mr. Bessel's face was
white and his expression anxious and
moreover that his hair was disordered
for a moment mr. Vincey in spite of his
state of expectation was too surprised
to speak or move and in that moment it
seemed to him as though the figure
glanced over its shoulder and
incontinently vanished it had been
arranged that an attempt should be made
to photograph any phantasm scene but Mr
Vincey had not the instant presence of
mind to snap the camera that lay ready
on the table beside him and when he did
so he was too late
greatly elated however even by this
partial success he made a note of the
exact time and it once took a cab to the
Albany to inform mr. Bessel of this
result he was surprised to find mr.
Bessel's outer door standing open to the
night and the inner apartments lit and
an extraordinary disorder an empty
champagne magnum Li smashed upon the
floor its neck had been broken off
against the inkpot on the bureau that
lay beside it an octagonal occasional
table which carried a bronze statuette
and a number of choice books had been
brutally overturned and down the
primrose paper of the wall inky fingers
had been drawn as it seemed for the mere
pleasure of defilement one of the
delicate chintz curtains had been
violently torn from its rings and thrust
upon the fire so that the smell of its
smouldering filled the room indeed the
whole place was disarranged in the
strangest fashion for a few moments mr.
Vincey who had entered sure of finding
mr. Bessel in his easy-chair awaiting
him could scarcely believe his eyes and
stood staring helplessly at these
unanticipated things then full of a
vague sense of calamity he sought the
porter at the entrance Lodge where is
mr. Bessel he asked do you know that all
the furniture is broken in mr. Bessel's
room the porter said nothing but obeying
his gestures came at once to mr.
Bessel's apartment to see the state of
affairs this settles it he said
surveying the lunatic confusion I didn't
know of this mr. Bessel's gone off he's
mad he then proceeded to tell mr. Vincey
that about half an hour previously that
is to say at about the time of mr.
Bessel's apparition into mr. vincey's
rooms the missing gentleman had rushed
out of the gates of the albany into Vigo
Street hatless and with disordered hair
and had vanished into the direction of
Bond Street and as he went past me said
the porter he laughed a sort of gasping
laugh with his mouth open and his eyes
glaring I tell you sir he fair scared me
like this according to his imitation it
was anything but a pleasant laugh he
waved his hand with all his fingers
crooked and clawing like that and he
said in a sort of fierce whisper life
just that one word life
dear me said Mr Vincey he could think of
nothing else to say he was naturally
very much surprised he turned from the
room to the porter and from the porter
to the room in the gravest perplexity
beyond his suggestion that probably mr.
Bessel would come back presently and
explained what had happened their
conversation was unable to proceed it
might be a sudden toothache
said the porter a very sudden and
violent toothache jumping on him
suddenly like and driving him wild I
broken things myself before now in such
a case he thought if it was why should
he say life to me as he went past mr.
Vincey did not know mr. Bessel did not
return and at last mr. Vincey having
done some more helpless staring and
having addressed a note of brief inquiry
and left it in a conspicuous position on
the bureau returned in a very perplexed
frame of mind to his own premises at
staple in this affair had given him a
shock he was at a loss to account for
mr. Bessel's conduct on any sane
hypothesis he tried to read but he could
not do so he went for a short walk and
was so preoccupied that he narrowly
escaped a cab at the top of Chancery
Lane and at last a full hour before his
usual time he went to bed for a
considerable time he could not sleep
because of his memory of the silent
confusion of mr. Bessel's apartment and
when at length he did attain an uneasy
slumber it was at once disturbed by a
very vivid and distressing dream of mr.
Bessel he saw mr. Bessel gesticulation
wildly and with his face white and
contorted and inexplicably mingled with
his appearance suggested perhaps by his
gestures was an intense fear an urgency
to act he even believes that he heard
the voice of his fellow experimenter
calling distressfully to him though at
the time he considered this to be an
illusion the vivid impression remained
though mr. Vincey awoke for a space he
lay awake and trembling in the darkness
possessed with that vague unaccountable
terror of unknown possibilities that
comes out of dreams upon even the
bravest men
but at last he roused himself and turned
over and went to sleep again
only for the dream to return with
enhanced vividness he awoke with such a
strong conviction that mr. Bessel was an
overwhelming distress in need of help
that sleep was no longer possible he was
persuaded that his friend had rushed out
to some dire calamity for a time he lay
reasoning vainly against this belief but
at last he gave way to it he arose
against all reason lit the gas and
dressed and set out through the deserted
streets deserted save for a noiseless
policeman or so in the early news carts
towards Vigo Street to inquire mr.
Bessel had returned but he never got
there as he was going down Long Acre
some unaccountable impulse turned him
aside out of that Street towards Covent
Garden which was just waking to its
nocturnal activities he saw the market
in front of him a queer effect of
glowing yellow lights and busy black
figures he became aware of a shouting
and perceived a figure turned the corner
by the hotel and run swiftly towards him
he knew at once that it was mr. Bessel
but it was mr. Bessel transfigured he
was hatless and disheveled his collar
was torn open he grasped a bone handled
walking cane near the ferrule end and
his mouth was pulled awry and he ran
with agile strides very rapidly their
encounter was the affair of an instant
Bessel cried Vincey the running man gave
no sign of recognition either of mr.
Vincey or of his own name instead he
cutted his friend savagely with a stick
hitting him in the face within an inch
of the eye mr. vincey's stunned and
astonished staggered back lost his
footing and fell heavily on the pavement
it seemed to him that mr. Bessel left
over him as he foul when he looked again
mr. Bessel had vanished and a policeman
and a number of garden porters and
salesmen were brushing past were
Longacre in hot pursuit
with the assistance of several
passers-by for the whole street was
speedily alive with running people mr.
Vincey struggled to his feet he at once
became the center of a crowd greedy to
see his injury a multitude of voices
competed to reassure him of his safety
and then to tell him of the behavior of
the madman as they regarded mr. Bessel
he had suddenly appeared in the middle
of the market screaming life life
striking left and right with a
blood-stained walking stick and dancing
and shouting with laughter at each
successful blow a lad and two women had
broken heads and he had smashed a man's
wrist a little child had been knocked
insensible and for a time he had driven
everyone before him so furious and
resolute had his behavior been then he
made a raid upon a coffee stall hurled
its paraffin flare through the window of
the post-office and fled laughing after
stunning the foremost of the two
policemen who had the pluck to charge
him mr. vincey's first impulse was
naturally to join in the pursuit of his
friend in order if possible to save him
from the violence of the indignant
people but his action was slow the blow
had half stunned him and while this was
still no more than a resolution came the
news shouted through the crowd that mr.
Bessel had eluded his pursuers at first
mr. Vincey could scarcely credit this
but the universality of the report and
presently the dignified return of two
futile policemen convinced him after
some aimless inquiries he returned
towards staple in patting a handkerchief
too and now very painful nose he was
angry and astonished and perplexed it
appeared to him indisputable that mr.
Bessel must have gone violently mad in
the midst of his experiment and thought
transference but why that should make
him appear with a sad white face and mr.
vincey's dreams seemed a problem beyond
solution he racked his brains in vain to
explain this it seemed to him at last
that not simply mr. Bessel but the order
of things must be insane but he could
think of nothing to do he shut himself
carefully into his room lit his fire it
was a gas fire with asbestos bricks and
fearing fresh dreams if he went to bed
remained bathing his injured face or
holding up books and a vain attempt to
read until dawn
throughout the vigil he had a curious
persuasion that mr. Bessel was
endeavoring to speak to him but he would
not let himself attend to any such
belief about dawn his physical fatigue
asserted itself and he went to bed and
slept at last in spite of dreaming he
rose late unrest adang shis and in
considerable facial pain the morning
papers had no news of mr. Bessel's
aberration it had come too late for them
mr. vincey's perplexities to which the
fever of his brews added fresh
irritation became at last intolerable
and after a fruitless visit to the
Albany he went down to st. Paul's
churchyard to mr. Hart mr. Bessel's
partner and so far as mr. Vincey knew
his nearest friend he was disturbed to
learn that mr. Hart although he knew
nothing of the outbreak had also been
disturbed by a vision the very vision
that mr. Vincey had seen mr. Bessel
white and disheveled pleading earnestly
by his gestures for help that was his
impression of the import of his signs I
was just going to look him up in the
Albany when you arrived said mr. Hart I
was so sure of something being wrong
with him at the outcome of their
consultation the two gentlemen decided
to inquire at Scotland Yard for news of
their missing friend he's bound to be
laid by the heels said mr. Hart he can't
go on at that pace for long but the
police authorities had not laid mr.
Bessel by the heels they confirmed mr.
vincey's overnight experiences and added
fresh circumstances some of an even
graver character than those he knew a
list of smashed glass along the upper
half of Tottenham Court Road an attack
upon a policeman in Hampstead Road and
an atrocious assault upon a woman all
these outrages were committed between
half-past twelve and a quarter to 2:00
in the morning and between those hours
and indeed from the very moment of mr.
Bessel's first rushed from his rooms at
half-past nine in the evening they could
trace the deepening violence of his
fantastic career for the last hour at
least from before one that is until a
quarter to two he had run amuck through
London eluding with amazing agility
every effort to stop or capture him
but after a quarter to two he had
vanished up to that our witnesses were
multitudinous dozens of people had seen
him fled from him or pursued him and
then things suddenly came to an end at a
quarter to two he had been seen running
down the houston road towards Baker
Street flourishing a can of burning
khalsa oil and jerking splashes of flame
therefrom at the windows of the houses
he passed but none of the policemen on
Houston Road beyond the waxwork
exhibition nor any of those in the side
streets done which he must have passed
had he left the Houston Road had seen
anything of him abruptly he disappeared
nothing of his subsequent doings came to
light in spite of the keenest inquiry
here was a fresh astonishment for mr.
Vincey he had found considerable comfort
in mr. Hart's conviction he's bound to
be laid by the heels before long and in
that assurance he had been able to
suspend his mental perplexities but any
fresh developments seemed destined to
add new impossibilities to a pile
already heaped beyond the powers of his
acceptance he found himself doubting
whether his memory might not have played
him some grotesque trick debating
whether any of these things could
possibly have happened and in the
afternoon he hunted up mr. Hartigan to
share the intolerable weight on his mind
he found mr. Hart engaged with a
well-known private detective but as that
gentleman accomplished nothing in this
case we need not enlarge upon his
proceedings all that day mr. Bessel's
whereabouts eluded an unceasingly active
inquiry and all that night and all that
day there was a persuasion in the back
of vincey's mind that mr. Bessel sought
his attention and all through the night
mr. Bessel with a tear-stained face of
anguish pursued him through his dreams
and whenever he saw mr. Bessel in his
dreams he also saw a number of other
faces vague but malignant that seemed to
be pursuing mr. Bessel it was on the
following day Sunday that mr. Vincey
recalled certain remarkable stories of
mrs. Bullock the medium who was then
attracting attention for the first time
in London he determined to consult her
she was staying at the house of that
well-known Inquirer
dr. Wilson paje and mr. Vincey although
he had never met that gentleman before
prepared to him forthwith with the
intention of invoking her help
but scarcely had he mentioned the name
of Bessel when dr. pate interrupted him
last night just at the end he said we
had a communication he left the room and
returned with a slate on which were
certain words written in a handwriting
shaky indeed but indisputably the
handwriting of mr. Bessel how did you
get this said Mr Vincey do you mean we
got it last night said dr. pate with
numerous interruptions from mr. Vincey
he proceeded to explain how the writing
had been obtained it appears that in her
seances mrs. Bullock passes into a
condition of trance her eyes rolling up
in a strange way under her eyelids and
her body becoming rigid she then begins
to talk very rapidly usually in voices
other than her own at the same time one
or both of her hands may become active
and if slates and pencils are provided
they will then write messages
simultaneously with and quite
independently of the flow of words from
her mouth by many she is considered an
even more remarkable medium than the
celebrated mrs. Piper it was one of
these messages the one written by her
left hand then mr. Vincey now had before
him it consisted of eight words written
disconnected Lee George Bessel rail
excavation Baker Street help starvation
curiously enough neither dr. posh a nor
the two other inquires who were present
had heard of the disappearance of mr.
Bessel the news of it appeared only in
the evening papers of Saturday and they
had put the message aside with many
others of a vague and enigmatic 'el sort
that mrs. Bullock has from time to time
delivered when dr. posh I heard mr.
vincey's story he gave himself at once
with great energy to the pursuit of this
clue to the discovery of mr. Bessel it
would serve no useful purpose here to
describe the inquiries of mr. Vincey and
himself suffice it that the clue was a
genuine one and that mr. Bessel was
actually discovered by its aid he was
found at the bottom of a detached shaft
which had been sunk and abandoned at the
commencement of the work for a new
electric railway
near Baker Street station his arm and
leg and two ribs were broken
the shaft is protected by a hoarding
nearly 20 feet high and over this
incredible as it seems mr. Bessel a
stout middle-aged gentleman must have
scrambled in order to fall down the
shaft he was saturated in khalsa oil and
the smashed in lay beside him but
luckily the flame had been extinguished
by his fall and his madness had passed
from him altogether but he was of course
terribly enfeebled and at the sight of
his rescuers he gave way to hysterical
weeping in view of the deplorable state
of his flat he was taken to the house of
dr. Hatton in Upper Baker Street here he
was subjected to a sedative treatment
and anything that might recall the
violent crisis through which he had
passed was carefully avoided but on the
second day he volunteered a statement
since that occasion mr. Bessel has
several times repeated this statement to
myself among other people varying the
details that the narrator of real
experiences always does but never by any
chance contradicting himself in any
particular and the statement he makes is
in substance as follows in order to
understand it clearly it is necessary to
go back to his experiments with mr.
Vincey before his remarkable attack mr.
Bessel's first attempts at self
projection and his experiments with mr.
Vincey were as the reader will remember
unsuccessful but through all of them he
was concentrating all his power and will
upon getting out of the body willing it
with all my might he says at last almost
against expectation came success and mr.
Bessel asserts that he being alive did
actually by an effort of will leave his
body and pass into some place or state
outside of this world
the release was he asserts instantaneous
at one moment I was seated in my chair
with my eyes tightly shut my hands
gripping the arms of the chair doing all
I could to concentrate my mind on Vincey
and then I perceived myself outside my
body saw my body near me but certainly
not containing me with the hands
relaxing and the head drooping forward
on the breast nothing shakes him in his
assurance of that release he describes
in a quiet matter-of-fact way the new
sensations he experienced he felt he had
become impalpable so much he had
expected but he had not expected to find
himself enormous ly large so however it
would seem he became I was a great cloud
if I may express it that way anchored to
my body it appeared to me at first as if
I had discovered a greater self of which
the conscious being in my brain was only
a little part I saw the Albany and
Piccadilly and Regent Street and all the
rooms and places in the houses very
minut and very bright and distinct
spread out below me like a little city
seen from a balloon every now and then
vague shapes like drifting wreaths of
smoke made the vision a little
indistinct but at first I paid little
heed to them the thing that astonished
me the most and which astonishes me
still is that I saw quite distinctly the
insides of the houses as well as the
streets saw little people dining and
talking in the private houses men and
women dining playing billiards and
drinking in restaurants and hotels and
several places of entertainment crammed
with people it was like watching the
affairs of a glass hive such were mr.
Bessel's exact words as I took them down
when he told me this story quite
forgetful of mr. Vincey he remained for
a space observing these things impelled
by curiosity he says he stooped down and
with the shadowy arm he found himself
possessed of attempted to touch a man
walking along Vigo Street but he could
not do so though his finger seemed to
pass through the man something prevented
him doing this but what it was he finds
hard to describe he compares the
obstacle to a sheet of glass I felt as a
kitten might feel he said when it goes
for the first time to pad its reflection
in a mirror
again and again on the occasion when I
heard him tell this story mr. Bessel
returned to that comparison of the sheet
of glass yet it was not altogether a
precise comparison because as the reader
will speedily see there were
interruptions of this generally
impermeable resistance means of getting
through the barrier to the material
world again but naturally there is a
very great difficulty in expressing
these unprecedented impressions in the
language of everyday experience a thing
that impressed him instantly and which
weighed upon him throughout all his
experience was the stillness of this
place he was in a world without sound at
first mr. Bessel's mental state was an
unemotional wonder his thought chiefly
concerned itself with where he might be
he was out of the body out of his
material body at any rate but that was
not all he believes and I for one
believe also that he was somewhere out
of space as we understand it all
together by a strenuous effort of will
he had passed out of his body into a
world beyond this world a world undreamt
of yet lying so close to it and so
strangely situated with regard to it
that all things on this earth are
clearly visible both from without and
from within in this other world about us
for a long time as it seemed to him this
realisation occupied his mind the
exclusion of all of their matters and
then he recalled the engagement with mr.
Vincey to which this astonishing
experience was after all but a prelude
he turned his mind to locomotion in this
new body in which he found himself for a
time he was unable to shift himself from
his attachment to his earthly carcass
for a time this new strange cloud body
of his simply swayed contracted expanded
coiled and rise too with his efforts to
free himself and then quite suddenly the
link that bound him snapped for a moment
everything was hidden by what appeared
to be whirling spheres of dark vapor and
then through a momentary gap he saw his
drooping body collapse limply saw his
lifeless head dropped sideways and found
he was driving along like a huge cloud
in this strange place of shadowy clouds
that had the luminous intricacy of
London spread like a model below
but now he was aware that the
fluctuating vapor about him was
something more than vapor and the temer
arias excitement of his first essay was
shot with fear for he perceived at first
indistinctly and then suddenly very
clearly that he was surrounded by faces
that each roll and coil of the seeming
cloud stuff was a face and such faces
faces of thin shadow faces of gaseous
tenuity faces like those faces that
glare with intolerable strangeness upon
the sleeper and the evil hours of dreams
evil greedy eyes that were full of a
covetous curiosity faces with knit brows
and snarling smiling lips their vague
hands clutched at mr. Bessel as he
passed and the rest of their bodies was
but an elusive streak of trailing
darkness never a word they said never a
sound from the mouths that seemed to
jibber all about him they pressed and
that dreamy silence passing freely
through the dim mistiness that was his
body gathering ever more numerous lay
around him and the shadowy mr. Bessel
now suddenly fear stricken drove through
the silent active multitude of eyes and
clutching hands so inhuman were these
faces so malignant in their staring eyes
and shadowy clawing gestures that it did
not occur to mr. Bessel to attempt
intercourse with these drifting
creatures idiot phantoms they seemed
children of vain desire beings unborn
and forbidden the boon of being whose
only expressions and gestures told that
the envy and craving for life that was
their one link with existence
it says much for his resolution that
amidst the swarming cloud of these
noiseless spirits of evil he could still
think of mr. Vincey he made a violent
effort of will and found himself he knew
not how stooping towards staple in saw
vincey's sitting attentive and alert in
his armchair by the fire and clustering
also about him as they clustered ever
about all that lives and breathes was
another multitude of these vain
voiceless shadows longing desiring
seeking some loophole into life for a
space mr. Bessel sought in effectually
to attract his friend's attention he
tried to get in front of his eyes to
move the objects in his room to touch
him but Mr Vincey remained unaffected
ignorant of the being that was so close
to his own the strange something that
mr. Bessel had compared to a sheet of
glass separated them impermeable and at
last mr. Bessel did a desperate thing I
told how that in some strange way he
could see not only the outside of a man
as we see him but within he extended his
shadowy hand and thrust his vague black
fingers as it seemed through the
heedless brain then suddenly mr. Vincey
started like a man who recalls his
attention from wandering thoughts and it
seemed to mr. Bessel that a little dark
red body situated in the middle of mr.
vincey's brain swelled and glowed as he
did so since that experience he has been
shown anatomical figures of the brain
and he knows now that this is that
useless structure as doctors call it the
pineal eye for strange as it will seem
to many we have deep in our brains where
it cannot possibly see any earthly light
and I at the time this with the rest of
the internal anatomy of the brain was
quite new to him at the sight of its
changed appearance however he thrust
forth his finger and rather fearful
still of the consequences touched this
little spot and instantly mr. Vincey
started and mr. Bessel knew that he was
seen and at that instant it came to mr.
Bessel that evil had happened to his
body and behold a great wind blew
through all that world of Shadows and
tore him away so strong was this
persuasion that he thought no more of
mr. Vincey but turned about forthwith
and all the countless faces drove back
with him like Lea's before a gale but he
returned too late in an instant he saw
the body that he had left inert and
collapsed lying indeed like the body of
a man just dead had arisen had arisen by
a virtue of some strength and will
beyond his own it stood with staring
eyes stretching its limbs in dubious
fashion for a moment he watched it in
wild dismay and then he stooped towards
it but the pane of glass had closed
against him again and he was foiled he
beat himself passionately against this
and all about him the spirits of evil
grinned and pointed and mocked he gave
way to furious anger he compares himself
to a bird that is fluttered heedlessly
into a room
is beating at the windowpane that holds
it back from freedom and behold the
little body that had once been his was
now dancing with delight he saw it
shouting though he could not hear its
shouts he saw the violence of its
movements grow he watched it fling his
cherished furniture about in the mad
delight of existence rend his books
apart smash bottles drink heedlessly
from the jagged fragments leap and smite
in a passionate acceptance of living he
washed these actions and paralyzed
astonishment then once more he hurled
himself against the impassable barrier
and then with all that crew of mocking
ghosts about him hurried back in dire
confusion to Vincey to tell him of the
outrage that had come upon him but the
brain of Vincey was now closed against
apparitions and the disembodied mr.
Bessel pursued him in vain as he hurried
out into Holborn to call a cab coiled
and terror stricken mr. Bessel swept
back again to find his desecrated body
whooping in a glorious frenzy down the
Burlington Arcade and now the attentive
reader begins to understand mr. Bessel's
interpretation of the first part of this
strange story the being whose frantic
rush through London had inflicted so
much injury and disaster had indeed mr.
Bessel's body but it was not mr. Bessel
it was an evil spirit out of that
strange world beyond existence into
which mr. Bessel had so rashly ventured
for 20 hours had held possession of him
and for all those twenty hours the
dispossessed spirit body of mr. Bessel
was going to and fro in that unheard-of
middle world of Shadows seeking help in
vain he spent many hours beating at the
minds of mr. Vincey and of his friend
mr. Hart each as we know was roused by
his efforts but the language that might
convey his situation to these helpers
across the Gulf he did not know his
feeble fingers groped vainly and
perilously in their brains
once indeed as we have already told he
was able to turn mr. Vincey aside from
his path so that he encountered the
stolen body in its career but he could
not make him understand the thing that
had happened he was unable to draw any
help from that encounter
all through those hours the persuasion
was overwhelming and mr. Bessel's mind
that presently his body would be killed
by his furious tenant and he would have
to remain in the shadow land forevermore
so that those long hours were a growing
agony of fear and ever is he hurried to
and fro in his ineffectual excitement
innumerable spirits of that world about
him mobbed him and Confused his mind and
ever an envious applauding multitude
poured over after their successful
fellow as he went upon his glorious
career for that it would seem must be
the life of these bodyless things of
this world that is the shadow of our
world ever they watch coveting away into
a mortal body in order that they may
descend as Furies and frenzies as
violent lusts and mad strange impulses
rejoicing in the body they have one for
mr. Bessel was not the only human soul
in that place witnessed the fact that he
first met one and afterwards several
shadows of men men like himself it
seemed who had lost their bodies even as
it may be he had lost his and wandered
despairingly in that lost world that is
neither life nor death they could not
speak because that world is silent yet
he knew them for men because of their
dim human bodies and because of the
sadness of their faces but how they had
come into that world he could not tell
nor where the bodies they had lost might
be whether they still raved about the
earth or whether they were closed
forever and death against return that
they were the spirits of the dead
neither he nor I believed but dr. Wilson
Pasha thinks they are the rational souls
of men who are lost in madness on the
earth at last mr. Bessel chanced upon a
place where a little crowd of such
disembodied silent creatures with
gathered and thrusting through them he
saw below a brightly lit room and four
or five quiet gentlemen and a woman a
stoutish woman dressed in black
bombazine and sitting awkwardly in a
chair with her head thrown back he knew
her from her portraits to be mrs.
Bullock the medium and he perceived that
tracts and structures and her brain
glowed and stirred as he had seen the
pineal eye in the brain of mr. Vincey
glow the light was very fitful sometimes
it was a broad illumination and
sometimes merely a faint Twilight spot
and it shifted slowly about her brain
she kept on talking and writing with one
hand and mr. Bessel saw that the
crowding shadows of men about him and a
great multitude of the shadow spirits of
that shadow land were all striving and
thrusting to touch the lighted regions
of her brain as one gained her brain or
another was thrust away her voice and
the writing of her hand changed so that
what she said was disorderly and
confused for the most part now a
fragment of one Souls message and now a
fragment of another's and now she
babbled the insane fancies of the
spirits of vain desire then mr. Bessel
understood that she spoke for the spirit
that had touch of her and he began to
struggle very furiously towards her but
he was on the outside of the crowd and
at that time he could not reach her and
at last growing anxious he went away to
find what had happened meanwhile to his
body for a long time he went to and fro
seeking it in vain and fearing that it
must have been killed and then he found
it at the bottom of the shaft in Baker
Street writhing furiously and cursing
with pain its leg and arm and two ribs
had been broken by its fall
moreover the evil spirit was angry
because his time had been so short and
because of the pain making violent
movements and casting his body about and
at that mr. Bessel returned with
redoubled earnestness to the room where
the seance was going on and so soon as
he had thrust himself within sight of
the place he saw one of the men who
stood about the medium looking at his
watch as if he meant that the seance
should presently end at that a great
number of the shadows who had been
striving turned away with gestures of
despair but the thought that the seance
was almost over
only made mr. Bessel the more earnest
and he struggled so stoutly with his
will against the others that presently
he gained the woman's brain it chanced
that just at that moment it glowed very
brightly and in that instant she wrote
the message that dr. Wilson Paget
preserved and then the other shadows and
the cloud of evil spirits about him had
thrust mr. Bessel away from her and for
all the rest of the seance he could
regain her no more
so he went back and watched through the
long hours at the bottom of the shaft
where the evil spirit lay in the stolen
body it had maimed writhing and cursing
and weeping and groaning and learning
the lesson of pain and towards dawn the
thing he had waited for happened the
brain glowed brightly and the evil
spirit came out and mr. Bessel entered
the body he had feared he should never
enter again as he did so the silence the
brooding silence ended he heard the
tumult of traffic and the voices of
people overhead and that strange world
that is the shadow of our world the dark
and silent shadows of ineffectual desire
and the shadows of lost men vanished
clean away he lay there for the space of
about three hours before he was found
and in spite of the pain and suffering
of his wounds and of the dim damp place
in which he lay in spite of the tears
wrung from him by his physical distress
his heart was full of gladness to know
that he was nevertheless back once more
in the kindly world of men